well you are gonna go on tour with Earth
Wind and Fire right this summer
I I mean Earth Wind and Fire and
Commodores have been like that forever I
mean and so this summer we're going to
travel across the U.S
[Applause]
yeah because they I know I know Drew is
going to bring Nicole yes and and Nicole
and Drew together as one big ham
sandwich so you have to understand I
don't even know how I'm going to take
that back Nicole and I have grown up in
and around each other we've known each
other for years we're dear friends we're
a part of this like little girl wolf
pack and
um I think Nicole and I have figured out
how to have so much fun and then pull it
together and be like really good moms or
care so much about it I don't even know
how that I don't even know how that
happened you know as parents you go
this is going to be a disaster because I
mean Nicole and Paris let's talk about
it when they started out yeah I mean if
I lived through that I can live through
anything
you know and then and
and then all of a sudden you know then
it became this little committee I call
him the bitty committee and then you go
this is no way that this is going to
transcend over into a family with
husbands and kids no way and it turned
out
perfectly exactly I don't know we turned
out all right
[Applause]
I think also like we got it all out of
our systems I love hearing it from your
side of the story really so let me give
you my side of the story please you all
almost kill me yeah
I'm so glad you got it out of your
system I almost cut my system off you
know what I'm saying I know I mean I
almost I I almost lost Consciousness
some nights I would get a phone call
uh Mr Richard yes this is the sheriff of
so-and-so County uh we have Nicole here
and I'm thinking myself
and what did she do now well uh she went
down the wrong way of the freeway and
I'm thinking to myself this is not
possible Right all I want to find out is
who's going to pay me back for all that
medication I took that's all I care
about um you don't see both of us well
someone someone said to me how did you
make it through all of this and I said I
was somewhere between meditation and
meditation yeah you know just you know
but we put you guys you have you have no
idea my Mom and Dad loved it when I came
in the house one day and I said Mom Dad
can you be this is what's going on my
dad starts laughing hysterically and
then I realized
I'm doing they're doing the same thing
that I did to my folks only worse
because they're doing it in Beverly
Hills and the problem is it would never
be allowed in Alabama you follow me in
Beverly Hills is oh it's okay Lionel
they're supposed to be able to have some
fun no no no grab my child pull my child
in the car and bring them home but in La
it's this freedom and justice for all no
there is no freedom of justice but she's
this is freedom and justice for all
right here we're doing it you're doing
very well you're doing better
Lionel Richie American Idol air Sunday
at 8 pm and streams on Hulu and you can
catch Lionel on tour starting August
Sports tickets are on sale now I'm
getting one
[Music]
foreign